اخبار كاس العالم هذه الايام هي اهم الناس
الاكبر والخبر الابراج والماسك اللي
بيعملوا في تويتر كمان عنوان مكمل معنا
فتخيلوا عاد لما يجتمعوا الاثنين في خبر
واحد طبيعي يكون عنواننا الاول استخدم كاس
العالم اليوم في حلقه جديده ضمن حلقات
مسلسل التباهي يتكلم عن النشاط اللي مسبب
المونديال على تويتر والشغل الي عامله
موظفي المنصه فغردقه قال انه كاس العالم
كان موضوع 20,000 تغريده في الثانيه امس
ومدح في العمل الرائع من فريق تويتر في
قياس معدلات الاستخدام للمنصه تباهي ماسك
كملوا احنا تعودنا خلاص انه بيحب الرسوم
البيانيه
اليوم نشر واحد منها وقال انه بيظهر
انخفاض خطاب الكراهيه على المنصه خلال
الشهر الماضي وبارك لموظفي تويتر هذا
جاد طبعا لازم ماسك يتبعها بهذا الشيء
لانه كثير من منتقديه بيتهموه انه بسبب
ارائكم ومواقفه خطاب الكراهيه راح يزيد
كانه بيوريهم انه يعني اللي جالس يصير هو
العكس وعلى سيره الانتقاد فماسك نشر فيديو
امس من مخزن لمنتجات تويتر اللي بيبيعوها
ومكتوب عليها هاشتاج ستاي ووك طبعا ابوك
يعني هذا المصطلح للاسف لسه ما تعرف بس هو
بيطلق على الافكار والمواقف اليسريه
الرافضه والمحاربه او المحاربه للتمييز
اعتمادا على الهويه سواء الجنسيه او
العرقيه او غيرها ومؤخرا صارت به يقصد في
المبالغه في الموضوع لحد التطرف يعني كانه
تطرف بس هذا من ناحيه انه الليبراليه
ماسك انتقدوا اكثر من مره وصفوا بيروت نشر
الفيديوهات
على هذه التيشرتات كانه بيقول لي العالم
شوفوا ان الاداره السابقه زي ما انا كنت
بقول لكم انهم اداره مو محايده وصاحبه
الجيولوجيه واليوم كم الحمله هذه ونشر صور
لنفس التيشرتات لكن مكتوب عليها ستاي ورك
بدل ستاي ووك جوجل انها بضائع جديده رائعه
من تويتر طبعا يعني عمل وماسك لعب على فرق
الحرف الواحد ويك
[موسيقى]